make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are continuing
on with our story on the eternals but
there's a few things that i want to
clear up here yes this bit of a battle
does face or really has like thanos
facing off against the eternals
more icarus than the rest of the
eternals but it's a battle between
the eternals and thanos nonetheless uh
but i also want to kind of talk about
thanos and how he relates to the
eternals now i know a lot of you guys
who have been around my channel for a
long time
already know this so kind of bear with
me for a minute because we got a whole
bunch of new subscribers with the
the icarus explained video that we did
and so on so thanos
is in and of himself an eternal but he's
an eternal with a deviant gene so
depending on what comic book fans you
talk to
some people will say that he's just a
deviant others will say that he's an
eternal with a deviant gene and some
will say he's a hybrid of both the
importance behind this is that thanos
is in some form or fashion tied into the
genetic makeup
of an eternal he was technically born to
both eternals he was born to sweet son
and lars both of whom are pure eternals
so again it's one of those weird little
concepts the reality of this
is that we can really look at thanos
more is like a mutant
among his own race in the same way that
like wolverine's considered a mutant
among the human race that thanos is the
same way that seemingly
every eternal has like a dormant deviant
gene but it just never seems to activate
and thanos is the unique exception among
his own people
where being born with a deviant gene
that deviant gene was
a primary gene that deviant gene was
basically a dominant gene
instead of a recessive gene and that's
why he looks the way he does now thanos
being a member of the eternals is
exceedingly important and the reason why
is because thanos being able to travel
through the eternal gates by way of the
machine
is something that can only truly be done
by a person who is of pure
eternal blood now a person who is not in
eternal can do it but they have to be
given passage by eternals essentially
they have to be given the key
to open the doors by the eternals
themselves but the important thing here
is
that with icarus having shown up at
basically the ruins of titanos finding
it more or less destroyed and thanos
occupying that space
the two of them get into a battle now
something that i want to stress here
this is the first time in marvel comics
that the eternals and really icarus
himself has actually fought thanos this
has never really happened before and so
in a lot of ways
you're kind of talking about what would
normally be an even battle between two
characters but one thing to keep in mind
thanos is banned from the realm of
mistress death he
is effectively immortal and so because
of that he has everything he needs in
order to essentially survive
whatever force he faces off against now
he's not immutable and indestructible if
his physical body
is incapable of surviving an experience
he'll more or less die that's one of
those instances where like drax the
destroyer comes into play right during
annihilation
thanos was technically banned from the
realm of mr steph but drax the destroyer
was able to kill him because it's a
power imparted to drax by the cosmic
entity kronos that drax can kill thanos
so it almost kind of triumphs or almost
kind of trumps the power of mistress
death not officially in the sense that
when thanos was killed his body simply
ceased to function because his heart was
ripped out so don't try to compare it
one for one like if iron man ripped out
the heart of thanos would he also stay
dead in that capacity this is one of
those instances when marvel just kind of
cooks the books for the purpose of
telling a story so it doesn't really
apply
universally across the board it's what
we call comic book logic it's a plot
device it just exists to tell a story
right so that's one of the unique
aspects of drax but the important thing
is the machine basically opens a portal
and then their fight actually takes
place through time now while these two
are fighting i want to kind of explain
the machine
a little bit so the machine as us
described to us was given to us in
eternals in 2006
but there really isn't much in the way
of explanation regarding what the
machine is that is to say
we don't know if it was created by the
eternals we don't know if it was created
by the celestials to control the
eternals we don't really know or really
have much information behind it all we
really know
is the machine is both itself a physical
device but it also represents the the
system of the eternals right their
hierarchy
how it is that they exist the idea of
bringing people back from the dead
different things like that that's all
part and parcel to the machine and so
the machine itself is kind of a coming
together of smaller machines in the
sense that if you remember our last
video
we talked about how there are different
tribes of eternals across the world
in the same way that you have like
different tribes of inhumans different
things along those lines while you have
eternals in different locations an
eternal in titanos can travel through
the gateway to an eternal and polaria
and much the same way with him going
vice versa and so it's smaller machines
that make all that possible and all
those small machines make up the larger
machines so again it's kind of weird
right it's like how all 50 states make
up the united states of america it's the
easiest way to understand that now the
important thing between the fight of
these two is that icarus was never going
to win the fight with thanos right that
was never going to happen and the reason
why is because icarus just doesn't have
the power to pull this off but at the
end of the day the fight between the two
is such that thanos overpowers icarus
and actually rips his head off
only for us to realize it was a
construct created by the machine but the
reality of thanos being able to pull
this off is that one
thanos is temporarily incapacitated and
two icarus and sprite get out of there
as fast as they can
because if thanos gets his hands on the
real icarus he'll kill him right that's
just the reality of the situation that
we're facing off against is that thanos
is just that much more powerful than the
eternals and so following that icarus
basically travels to olympus right
basically where the eternals are
currently residing and meets with the
rest of them and effectively tells them
thanos is here on earth and thanos is
the reason why all this happened now i
wouldn't go so far as to say the
eternals panic but they do understand
the threat of the situation
one of the other things they refer to
thanos as is the sin of titan during the
original thanos rising storyline and
even before that back in the day it was
kind of established by jim starlin
thanos effectively eradicated all of his
race on titan right that there were a
lot of eternals who lived there and
during his journey when he was
manipulated by mistress death he
actually left titan and then eventually
he came back with an army he had amassed
and eradicated everybody there it's
considered
a unconscionable sin for somebody for an
eternal to basically commit genocide
against their own kind to take out the
entirety of the eternals race or at
least those eternals who lived on uh
lived on titan that was unheard of under
normal circumstances a crime like that
thanos would be locked in the exclusion
zone but there was no one there to stop
him right thanos was of such a power to
where nobody could really stand against
him
and so that's why he's considered to be
the sin of titan because thanos is the
eternal who went awry right he's the
eternal he became a bad guy
blinked out half the life in the
universe during the original infinity
gauntlet story has done things like that
time and time again where he's been a
credible threat not just to earth or
even the eternals on titan but to the
universe as a whole and so because of
that the question becomes
what are we going to do here but the
funny thing about this is that while
icarus pleads with the eternals
some of them don't actually believe that
thanos is here that surely somebody
would have noticed that that was the
case and so it's one of these things
where when icarus says that thanos had
actually traveled through the eternal
gates they kind of say well thanos is
not a true eternal but the answer to
that question is if thanos is not a true
eternal how is he able to travel the
eternal gates if nobody gave him
permission to do so
and so only one of two things is
possible here either we're basically
looking at marvel telling us
thanos is really a true eternal he just
has the deviant gene
or the history of thanos is still intact
in the sense that because he had the
deviant gene
it's like putting iodine in a drop of
water it permeates and it kind of makes
him an impure eternal
and not a true eternal which is kind of
what his history's sort of been again
depending on what comic book fan you
talk to and how marvel interprets that
the important thing here is that
if he's not necessarily a true eternal
then it means somebody let him in that
means that
there's basically a spy among their
ranks or a traitor and somebody is
essentially letting him into this place
the other part of that is when they had
traveled to the exclusion zone in an
attempt to find out when zoros was going
to be resurrected due to the fact that
he's the prime eternal the news they get
is that all the wardens in the exclusion
zone are dead there's nobody there to
resurrect zoros and so in essence the
dead will stay dead
this is exceedingly important and the
reason why is because what it means is
there's no resurrection for the eternals
that marvel as the
if the eternals start dying over the
course of the story marvel's effectively
thinning the herd if i'm a betting man
here the reason why marvel will be doing
this is because they're going to thin
the roster down so the comic book roster
matches the marvel cinematic universe
roster it's kind of what marvel comics
does now marvel follows the mcu as
opposed to the mcu following marvel but
again it's kind of an interesting
concept because in the midst of all that
while all this kind of accusation is
going on with regards to druid and kind
of pointing the finger
at icarus and saying hey man you've had
time you've had opportunity
you know to take out xeros so that you
could kind of take your place back as
the prime eternal that's what you wanted
to do maybe your anger or jealousy that
zoros replaced you as the prime eternal
whatever logic makes sense to you
and then you come to us with the story
about how the sin of titan the mad titan
himself
thanos has somehow made his way to earth
with no one knowing he's here and he's
the one behind it all
what a convenient excuse right what a
convenient finger to point that it's
thanos that caused all this
and so cersei ultimately pops up and
says no right this is not going to
happen
even if there is some measure of truth
to what you're saying druid which
there's not but even if it was something
like icarus who did all this
now is not the time for eternals to turn
against eternals that's not what needs
to happen here the biggest problem with
this that you have is kind of a bit of
an emergency going on at the moment is
the machine is effectively failing that
if a portion of the machine is damaged
then the entire machine is damaged
what's kind of going on here is that by
virtue of thanos presumably thanos
wiping out all those wardens in the
exclusion zone and then destroying the
portion of the machine that deals with
with
resurrecting uh eternals who have died
it's like pulling out the bottom piece
on a jenga set at the wrong time
it's only a matter before it all comes
crashing down and when that happens
because the machine is tied into the
biosphere of earth if the machine fails
the biosphere of earth fails
basically it becomes an uninhabitable
planet this i would say is something i
can do a plot device to a degree but not
necessarily at least that'd be kind of
the throwaway or the immediate response
but the nature of the eternals is that
they are tied irrevocably into the
existence of the earth itself
and assuming the machine was created by
the celestials and left here to control
the eternals what better way to do that
than to tie the habitability of the
planet into the machine itself
right keep the machine intact make sure
it runs like it's supposed to and you'll
continue to survive it's one of those
interesting concepts that marvel sort of
throws in there
and so ultimately the questions asked of
the machine uh who did this right like
who gave thanos the ability to
travel here to earth by way of the
eternal gateways and the response of the
machine is
i can find no data on the exception i'm
unable to remove that exception
in effect what it looks like is again
one of two things either thanos is a
true eternal and can travel from one
gateway to the other which they more or
less said that can't be the case
or there's somebody who allowed who made
an exception for thanos and then wiped
that exception from the database so once
thanos was here they removed the
exception and so as far as the machine
is concerned there was no exception and
so there's no exception to remove so in
essence if there is a traitor they snuck
thanos on board earth to wipe out the
rest of the eternals we don't
necessarily know who that person is or
why they would have done it at the
moment because the story follows icarus
there's really nothing he can do here
right i mean there is a little bit of
speculation that sprite might be
involved but nothing of any real
seriousness here and so at this point
it's really more of a whodunit mystery
who brought thanos to earth and why are
they allowing thanos to kill off all the
various eternals across the planet and
so what you end up doing is actually
traveling to new york to toby robson
because as we saw in the previous story
there was a kind of vision that icarus
got
that toby robson had essentially been
killed and icarus saw it as a failing of
his now there is a kind of motivation
behind this which actually sort of jumps
back to a previous moment in icarus's
life when he had stumbled across a man
who kind of existed on an island and
basically asked him have you seen a
monster of course referring to the
deviants and when the answer the remain
of the man is i've never seen a monster
like that the only monster he has is a
kind of fish then he basically tells him
build up higher here and that when a
monster comes or when a deviant comes
light the pyre and then i will respond
but because of the fact that no deviance
came over the course of this man's life
this guy quite literally just
sat there waiting for monsters to show
up they never did and so he ended up
just kind of dying here now icarus
eventually showed up when the man was
basically buried by his family and the
pyre was lit in order to burn his body
and icarus thought a monster had been
summoned this is really kind of designed
to tie into the nature of icarus himself
this is one of the things that we
explained when we talked about his
character explanation and the video that
we did which you'll find down in the
description that icarus has lived for
countless eons and so what would be
90 years is just a blink of an eye in
his life it might be minutes as far as
his mind comprehends it and so the
result of this is that when he tells the
sky
stay here and light up higher so that if
the monsters ever return then i'll be
here to fight them that this man's life
was 90 years
for icarus it just felt like a matter of
minutes and so the people here his
family just scream and cuss
at icarus because of the fact that
basically this man wasted his life he
just
sat there and just waited for monsters
to show up and they never did but
ultimately a giant deviant arrives here
and it really kind of shines into sharp
relief the fact that presumably over the
course of this man's life he told them
of the mission that was given to him by
what he perceived to be a god and while
they kind of wrote it off as being
nonsense and
ridiculous in this moment the man's
words all hail supreme but it's really a
small comfort to his family because at
the end of the day he still wasted his
life right and so again that seems to be
why icarus is really looking to protect
toby robson the way he is because it's
more or less kind of making amends for a
previous failure over the course of his
life but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace